uh welcome to this lightning talk we are
a startup we started about two years ago
and um
i'm here today to tell about
what kind of thinking went into
designing orchest an orchestrator tool
to build data pipelines
and
why when we started we felt that there
was a need for a different type of
orchestrator in the market
and i'm actually going to dive into a
bit of the
underlying implementation of how we
built it because we think you know
there's a technical crowd maybe it's
interesting to talk a bit more about how
we actually implemented stuff and it
also i think gives you a good sense of
the philosophy and i think you'll find
some concepts that are similar maybe
people who are familiar with kubeflow
recognize some of the architectural
choices we've made
but really i want to start with
telling what frustrated us with the
existing orchestrated ecosystem
and where we felt that there was a need
for some um for an orchestrator that
really played much more into the
style of working that we as data
scientists ourselves felt was a natural
or more natural fit
when developing out these uh workflow uh
workflows um that have all kinds of data
science processing
so
um in the uh in the video that i'm about
to show i'll narrate it a live but i'll
go into three of the core concepts of
the tool and we really wanted to bring
the iteration side and the ex the
exploration side uh closer to the
production uh productionization process
so that there's not so much of a gap
between when you start out with a more
idea that's run unstructured maybe you
have a single notebook or python script
and then you want to move into a more
production oriented context how do we
bring those two worlds together and so
i'll show three features one being
integrating with existing code bases so
you have some existing code you have
some existing scripts or notebooks that
you're starting with as a starting point
how do you
use that existing starting point and
define a good environment that really
matches with the dependency needs that
you have in that project
orchest is a language agnostic
orchestrator so those environments need
to support a very diverse set of
runtime uh
requirements so it can run both python
julia r even bash based data processing
pipelines so in that sense it's really
kind of at the layer of a container and
not so much at the level of a
programming framework like python
the second major thing we're showing
is the iterative capacities and this
really comes down to the deep support
for jupiter kernels that are running
inside a cluster and offer you a
scalable way to have experimentation
part of that pipeline development
workflow
and then the final thing is really the
productionization so how do you go from
some notebooks and scripts to a
well-defined workflow that you can run
in production capacity as a batch job on
a recurring schedule and how do we
support that functionality by extending
the existing open source frameworks and
tools that exist by building on top of
frameworks like argo
so here's to
the demo godzilla the video has started
so
i'm starting off by importing an
existing project from github
this project contains existing files and
really any existing repository can be
imported directly into orcis and you can
kind of bolt on a data pipeline without
having to change the code itself
so what you're seeing is the files as a
central
starting point for your data pipeline
and you can
start to define that environment like i
mentioned that really just takes
advantage of the existing
files inside your project so in this
case i'm running a pip install
of the requirements
text and i think this is generally a
pretty important point dependency
management in a fast moving open source
ecosystem is really critical
because some people want to use
conda some people want to use pip some
people even have more well-defined
bundles
and so
being able to run
these environment builds in real time
allow you to iterate on the dependencies
and what you just saw was it running
in the background on a container that's
running inside the kubernetes cluster
that's doing the building and again this
is really for the interactivity so you
can very easily change your dependencies
all from the browser and rebuild the
container images to fit your your
project and what you also see is that
again we have pretty wide support for
different programming styles and
environments so maybe you want to use an
r based based image or julia based base
image and
we are all about
flexibility so if you want to bring
a
custom container image instead of fine
tuning it using orchest setup scripts
that's also totally fine so
that's the environment image building
now onto the kind of interactive way of
you know creating and defining the
actual pipeline you can just kind of
drag in the files and define a pipeline
that way
and it really just creates a json file
that's part of the repository that can
be versioned so you have a good version
history of the definition of the full
pipeline but again we're not changing
anything in the files
works is kind of designed as a workbench
so it provides this kind of development
interactivity and it allows you to edit
any of the files and keep developing and
coding the the pipeline steps themselves
so you're not stuck with whatever you
kind of imported in it's really the the
idea that you can keep changing and
iterating on the definition
of your code as you're building out the
pipeline
this interactivity shows that the
the kernel that was just spawned is
really just spawned as a container on
the cluster and by tapping into
jupiter enterprise gateway
we basically have this very scalable
approach
to
having interactivity when you're
prototyping and iterating on these
pipelines with a big team on a single
large cluster and so that cluster
approach really allows you to scale um
a data platform inside the existing data
infrastructure because typically you're
consuming data from
some data warehouse that is located
somewhere and we're really big fans of
pushing that data processing layer close
to where your existing infrastructure
sits
so what you're seeing now is that the
kernel is aware of what's happening in
the pipeline definition so the the code
inside of the first cell actually is
able to import data that comes from the
the first step so we have integrated
support for data passing
and
you know this
iterative environment is really built on
top of kubernetes and i'll have a slide
later that goes into
the full architecture and what we depend
on
but i'd like to end with this example of
a job where you have this defined
pipeline and you can run and create this
job
and in the background it's spawning an
argo workflow to
execute and orchestrate across the
resources of the cluster but as a user
this is kind of transparent to you and
that's really the goal it's the goal to
have an orchestrator that doesn't
require you as a data scientist or as a
data analyst to be super familiar and
aware
of all of the kind of underlying
orchestration and scheduling that's
going on at a lower level
of the compute layer
so
i think that's pretty much what i wanted
to show in the video
you have the job it's running so we went
all the way from an existing code base
imported defined the pipeline
added it
added the environment specification
we're able to productionize it as a job
and now this thing is running and the
jobs are created as kind of immutable
structure so the moment we keep changing
things we keep iterating that job is
unaffected it will just run the pipeline
itself
so
what's actually going on behind the
scenes so how is this
you know architected
and what you see is that we have this
independent configuration where it's
basically a collection of of container
services and the control pane is running
kind of everything you see as a user
from orcas itself so it's really kind of
the authoring
set of containers that are responsible
for your development environment that's
kind of the workbench part of it
and on the other on the other side you
basically see that pipelines have their
own independent set of containers that
are running as part of that pipeline and
that's both the pipeline steps but also
these kernels that provide this
interactivity in the notebooks and so
this architecture really allows us to
scale to a cluster with hundreds of
nodes because from the kubernetes
perspective it doesn't really matter
where you're running the kernels when
you're prototyping doesn't really matter
where the pipeline steps are running so
this allows us to kind of intelligently
entitle intelligently behind the scenes
optimize the usage
so two deep dives the kernels like i
mentioned we're depending on the jupiter
enterprise gateway project it's a
phenomenal open source project that
allows you to spawn kernels outside of
where the jupiter lab itself is running
so it creates this network bridge for
the kernel that we are extending
in orchest to basically make it easy to
have these kernels be part of your
pipeline development workflow
and then the second part like the
environment building
we actually had a bit of choice which is
really nice to have a bit of choice
for these types of components and the
way we developed the image building is
really to have image building as its
separate container process which again
allows us to scale to multiple users in
the same cluster so if you have you know
four data scientists building their own
environments which can typically uh
consume a lot of resources maybe there's
io being used for installing packages
sometimes you know by charge 700
megabytes so that can can count up and
so that really allows us to scale not
just the pipeline running but also the
whole development workflow of the the
pipelines
um so we're really happy to announce
here at data council that the kubernetes
version is going to be fully part of the
open core so it's licensed under an open
source license and everybody can
self-host this uh this has been a number
one requested feature since we started
but it was just a lot of engineering
work to get it all to work and so we
bought it from docker to kubernetes over
the past months and uh yeah we're really
happy to now have this on github so you
can go and deploy in your cluster and
figure out if this orchestrator fits
your team of data scientists
better than maybe some of the more lower
level
alternatives that are out there
i would be remiss if i didn't give some
credit to the team i'm standing up here
but of course i didn't do this all by
myself so my co-founder was sitting
there and we have a bunch of folks back
in europe uh fully distributed company
and um they really really worked super
super hard to get the kubernetes version
done in time for data council so massive
kudos to them for doing that
i think it's good to highlight a little
bit of project continuity you see a lot
of startups here today and you're
sometimes wondering like okay is this
project going to be around in a year or
so because if i'm going to use something
i need to be certain that it's going to
be around so we are really proud to be
able to partner with you know best in
class investors from basis set to
gradient and seed camp
we've been able to really take the long
view with our company because we now
have these these backers and i think
that allows us to have both an open core
offering and and think about
commercialization later we are
transparent in that we're saying we're
open core company so we're going to open
source as much as we can but there will
also be a commercial offering and we
really try to combine the best of those
two
to give something to the community but
also have a viable a viable company
so
to end it's really just a call to action
we actually
coincidentally were trending on github
just today uh we got a shout out from
someone and we were getting some
community love so if you can go to
orgs.org github you can check it out you
can play with a repository look at the
code fork it all the good stuff you can
do with open source software so that's
always the most fun part for me when i
see a new project just kind of like
glancing at the code seeing how to do
things um yeah that's pretty much it so
thank you for attention this was uh this
was
[Applause]
you